where do you think abortion should be  legal at like at what point  it has to be your choice  it has to be the choice of the person  this  so if I'm enable in life so if I if I  you know like what human right are you  protecting you know are you protecting  the human right of the person that's  actually carrying it at what stage so so  I'm saying like if I wanted to get an  abortion I'm going to give birth in  three days  can I because like that's illegal for a  reason no I I agree with you so I'm  saying like I think we'd have some  common ground on like where it should be  like at least at certain points at eight  months nine months it should be illegal  so